hey guys I'm Alessandra Ambrosio and I'm
hearing my tree and this is my behind
the scenes of my photo shoot for GQ so
come with me and I'm gonna show you all
the insides because today it was all
about sucker
hey Jamie see I told you guys wait let
me start filming this too and see how
it's done a GQ cover photo shoot so here
this is my dressing room right here and
that's where it's done and this
Christian oh if you guys don't know what
the best player of [ __ ] you know in
the world
okay so guy
this is cristianos area I'm gonna show
every where there was shots now I don't
oh yeah and I'm gonna show you because
it's not in America yet but it should be
and all device to be getting there okay
okay yeah it's easy just get one like
that okay so we started here that's what
we started the first shot we did today
it was playing cards and Christiano was
really like playing with the cards
okay guys so now I'm going to show you
downstairs where all most of our shots
happen and it was pretty fun because we
were playing foosball down there and I
don't know really who won because in the
end it all ended with like throwing
water on each other so I hope you guys
enjoy the behind the scenes of my GQ
cover photo shoot I have I had a lot of
fun I hope you guys will have it too and
get a little taste of how it is to be
with one of the best soccer players in
the world okay bye guys